Як ми робимо, щоб тепло нам було? Дмухаєм на ручки. І розігріваємо, так?
Отак грієм ручки, правда, дітки?
Це молодша група в дитячому садку "Берізка" в Тетієві на Київщині.
Дітки повертаються з прогулянки - надворі тепер тепліше, ніж у групі.
Під обід позначка термометра може піднятися до +10. Зранку тут набагато холодніше.
Вихователі, як і діти, одягаються за принципом капусти.
Ось дивіться. Один, два, три, чотири, шість футболок.
Мама вбирає дитину тепло, тому що мама на роботі, нема з ким покинути дитину вдома.
Найскладніше завдання дорослих - покласти в такому холоді дітей спати.
Щоби малюки не лякалися холодного ліжечка, няня діє за відпрацьованою схемою -
у порожні пластикові пляшки з відра наливає гарячу воду, міцно закручує корок
і кладе кожному під ковдру. Така саморобна грілка може за півгодини зігріти ліжечко малюку.
Однак батьків, які готові віддати свою дитину на цілий день в таку холоднечу, мало:
із шістдесяти малюків сьогодні прийшло лише п'ятнадцять.
Я не лишаю тут дитину на денний сон, бо вона тут змерзне. А потім вона просто захворіє,
і ми будемо сидіти вдома.
Кому точно доводиться сидіти вдома - то це школярам.
Місцеві чиновники оголосили канікули на тиждень раніше, ніж планувалося.
Офіційно - через ковід, але також кажуть, що цього тижня їм має вистачити,
аби дати раду з опалювальним сезоном.
Голова Тетіївської ОТГ Богдан Балагура оголосив про режим надзвичайної ситуації
через зрив опалювального сезону. Так само вчинили ще кілька громад на Київщині,
а також цілі області. Йдеться про Закарпатську, Івано-Франківську, Хмельницьку,
Одеську та Дніпропетровську області.
Ну, дивіться, торік ціна була з коливаннями 8 гривень. І в нас вже були проведені тендери.
Але ситуація склалася так, що ці компанії ще літом почали масово розривати контракти,
бо ціна, я так розумію, пішла вгору. І тепер наші бюджетні організації лишилися без договорів.
Паніка на порталі "прозорро" почалася ще у вересні. Після зриву контрактів
громади масово кинулися оголошувати нові тендери, платити втридорога,
аби тільки встигнути до початку холодів.
Протягом минулого тижня очікувана ціна закупівлі газу на тендерних процедурах
зросла з 29 тисяч грн до 41 тисячі за тисячу кубометрів газу.
Меморандум між мерами міст, Кабміном і "Нафтогазом" мав би частково
врегулювати ситуацію. В українській газовій компанії два тижні готували нові контракти.
І ось нарешті минулого тижня оголосили, що ціна для лікарень, шкіл і садків
буде втричі меншою за ринкову - 13,7 гривень за метр кубічний без ПДВ і транспортування.
Ті ж бюджетні установи, які виходили на ринок і купували газ у компаній "рога та копита",
зараз відповідно будуть ставити такі вимоги до постачальників,
щоб тільки надійні постачальники могли брати участь у тендерах.
Так-от Антимонопольний комітет не буде казати, що ці вимоги є надлишковими,
що вони обмежують конкуренцію. Бо важливо, щоб конкуренція була
не поміж "рогами та копитами", а поміж надійних постачальників,
які дійсно можуть виконувати свої зобов'язання.
Тоді це справжня конкуренція, а не імітація.
Топ-чиновники "Нафтогазу" збираються спрямувати на потреби населення за пільговою ціною газ,
видобутий державною компанією "Укргазвидобування".
Замість очікуваного видобутку 20 млрд кубометрів газу, компанія наразі
не вийшла навіть на позначку 14 млрд кубометрів.
Саме стільки кубометрів газу споживають українці за умов більш-менш помірної зими.
Наразі у сховищах - 19 млрд кубометрів газу,
але частина з нього - не український газ, і може бути викачаний до Європи.
Юрій Вітренко наразі вгамовує паніку і запевняє, що газу вистачить.
Однак аналітики, які давно стежать за цими іграми на тендерних ринках,
у цьому сумніваються.
У нас просто фізично не вистачить палива, якщо на вулиці буде така зима, як минулого року.
Така нехардова, не страшна. Та ми не очікували. Наша влада дуже швидко
витрачала гроші на "Велике будівництво", додавала туди нових і нових мільярдів.
Але подумати про те, що нафтогазівські мільярди треба зберегти саме для опалення -
вони не додумалися. Наприклад, мільярд доларів, який у "Нафтогазу" залишався
від перемоги над "Газпромом" у Стокгольмському арбітражі.
Мільярд доларів цей забрали, щоби витратити на асфальтування доріг.
Домовленість між містами не піднімати тариф для населення і фіксована ціна на газ
від "Нафтогазу" може лише частково врятувати зиму, що насувається.
Але не зніме ОТГ із газової голки в цілому.
У Тетієві тим часом утеплюють стіни школи тепловатою і заготовляють дрова для котельні.
Місцева влада каже, що вони хотіли б також повністю перевести бюджетні установи
на альтернативні види палива. Але компанії, які цим займаються,
не завжди зацікавлені в таких дрібних об'єктах, як, наприклад,
дитсадок "Берізка" в Тетієві.
Ми плануємо і хочемо перейти на альтернативне паливо.
Але це потребує першочергових фінансових інвестицій.
Вкладень в обладнання, реконструкцію цих котелень - у середньому таке окупиться за 5-6 років.
Непевна ситуація з тендерами, високі ціни на газ і водночас криза з видобутком вугілля
можуть значно прискорити процес переходу на альтернативні джерела
опалення та електроенергії, вважають експерти.
Українські міста стикаються з відсутністю дешевих довгих кредитів
і це є найбільшою проблемою, яка не дозволяє провести модернізацію.
Від моменту, коли "Нафтогаз" оголосив про нову ціну і процедуру укладення договорів,
минув тиждень. За цей час громади, серед них і Тетіївська, вже встигли подати
електронні заяви на укладення нових договорів.
Скільки часу потрібно відомству, аби опрацювати заявки зі всієї України,
у "Нафтогазі" не кажуть. За словами Вітренка, вирішують проблему
"у супер терміновому режимі".